hier après midi quelques minutes avant
de voter marie-guite dufay semblait
nager en plein doute
vous savez un tunnel qui ça chaque
s'achève
c'est tellement tellement est certain
tellement tellement inattendu avec ce
taux d'abstention est ce un signe
elle n'a pas reçu par la poste toutes
les professions de foi
hier j'ai reçu un courrier les documents
officiels action fois eh ben je vous le
donne en mille il ya tous les doutes
août tous les candidats sauf ont arrêté
quelques heures plus tard à dijon la
présidente de région arrive tout sourire
les premiers résultats la donnent
largement gagnant un peu plus c'était
monsieur odoul qui était qui était
pressenti pour être président de cette
région pendant un certain nombre de
semaines on a quand même entendu ça en
boucle
donc je mesure la responsabilité qui est
la mienne et je vous jure
la joie et la satisfaction du travail
accompli une victoire haut la main à
plus de 42 % des voix le pari d'un
ancrage à gauche réussit la dynamique de
rassemblement que j'ai voulu elle a payé
je vois que même au on va au delà que
cette dynamique de rassemblement
merci beaucoup y at il eu un coup de
pouce des électeurs de la république en
marche la gauche l'admet partiellement
un moment quand
dans leur infinie la question qui se
pose c'est est ce que le futur où la
future plus dans nos régions s'appellera
julian aux doudous marie-guite dufay
vous avez un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens qui en
conscience font le choix de voter pour
marine et du félicitations
sans elle rien n'aurait été possible
voilà on a une belle responsabilité
devant nous la fusion avec la candidate
écologiste replace les verts dans le
parlement régional puis la fusion il n'y
avait plus d'écologistes et c'est bien
aussi un autre raison de cette
satisfaction quand même ce soir c'est de
pouvoir de nouveau être à la région dont
1 franche-comté reste est à fêter cette
victoire devant une petite assemblée de
militants jusqu'au bout cette élection
n'aura pas soulevé les foules
[Applaudissements]